here's a peek at what guests have to say
after the show we're here back on the
Internet uh Amy does America still have
the triple package qualities it needs to
be successful I actually think it does I
think it does it as we've always had a
sense of exceptionality what we lost I
think exactly but what we always also
had until the former Soviet Union fell
is a dash of insecurity we were the
underdog we were always trying to prove
ourself that our system of democracy and
equality were better than the Monarchs
and I think that's actually what we lost
in the last twenty or thirty years so I
think that I do I think it's I think
this new this is related to that
commercial I think it's a new sense that
you know we had better get our act
together
we need to prove ourselves and do better
so I'm an optimist okay Seth what has
changed in our knowledge of the cosmos
since the original show premiered now
that's interesting Wow I learned
anything since this is was that a
question hating this is a question for
Neil deGrasse Tyson
the first exoplanet were discovered in
the midnight and didn't they throw Pluto
out at one they threw Pluto yes yellow
threw Pluto out but I think unless I'm I
was tough he threw it yes Pluto was
drunk it is it has been a blue eye I
think in the in the mid nineties we
discovered the first planets outside our
solar system that we were able to
actually detect so I think that's a
significant development that's taking
place since the first show aired um is
he is he gonna save billions and
billions of stars you yeah he's got at
some point you know what I loved at the
end when he said I never realized that
that when he was a 17 year old kid
oh yeah ethica yeah and there is a sort
of a personal passing of that legacy
between him and Carl he's the perfect
guy to do this job yeah yeah for that
reason among others okay um Alan
Weitzman given that Americans
overwhelmingly think of consumption as
our main problem and not overpopulation
how do you think we can activate a shift
in cultural norms to address this
problem if I knew the answer that when I
would have written a book about
consumption
as someone I interviewed for this such
an erudite way of saying [ __ ] you
so someone I interviewed for the book
pointed out that there's no condom for
consumption uh right yeah just there
just right what will the grand old
Steven foster son well yeah what we're
all addicted to stuff like energy
there's no option but what we can do is
we control the number of this so we made
it up and we both knew how did that work
out I don't think maybe we aren't meant
to be together I don't know yeah let's
let's get this party going okay uh who
is your favorite u.s. politician from a
party you don't usually associate with
well we were talking about Rand Paul I
mean he's like his father I love half of
them you know I I don't really have a
favorite politician I kind of yeah well
I you know I have to say maybe but Obama
I mean maybe maybe my mama has a way of
like he he he loses you he loses you and
then he does something like I saw him a
couple of weeks ago talking to those
black kids at the White House and he was
like so amazingly honest when he said
that thing about you know when I was
young I got high oh I was [ __ ] blitzed
and it was just so raw and real and he's
like he's like Michael Corleone and
Godfather 3 he pulls me back I think
he's a I just think it's a much a much
greater president than the polls
currently suggesting history will say I
really I really do yeah because first of
all he stopped a depression you know
that I mean we can
we can now actually have a comparative
rating of that we can look at every
other country went through the same
thing right where we are and where they
are and we are currently the bat and we
even beat Germany out of this and and
that was not a given when you can you
imagine what he would been able to do if
he had like one degree of cooperation
well that's that's it baby to me is what
he's done without it
I mean he's gay winding out he's
grinding out with with brutal opposition
he's grinding out the possibility of
universal health care in this country
which is a epochal event in American
social policy
he's also grinding out a saner
post-imperial foreign policy right I
think fact basically he will have to be
part of this country's DNA for now he's
resided over a civil rights revolution
with gay rights in a way that also no
one quite saw happening he's not exactly
getting rid of the American Empire I
don't know where you're getting that
from I mean he's no he's not he's not in
gate he's a he's a he's a pragmatist
but no he got us out of Afghanistan he's
getting us out of Iraq the way he's
handling these other player first he got
us more into Afghanistan yeah in order
to get out but you know he's a realist
and ya know III had to be a to Nokia
yourself against being told you're weak
that's right um and it didn't even work
but you can only do it right great to
prove to John McCain the story never
[ __ ] worked isn't didn't work in
Afghanistan it's a big [ __ ] to get
us out of there with by the waiting face
this one the paper today that in Iraq
the Shiites there are pushing through a
bill in their Parliament to legalize
child marriage as young as nine so isn't
that great mission accomplished
that we go for a rack and put the
g---eight sin charge so they could
legalize marriage to a nine year old
meanwhile the murder rate the sectarian
motive yeah or as a but getting back to
the state they were before before we
threw all those troops out it okay um
sab do you think now that cosmos has
been updated and relaunched that it will
create a renewed interest in science and
thus furthered the debate between
science versus faith you know when Carl
Sagan was alive he would meet with
religious leaders and say look we both
recognize that climate change is a
problem me for scientific reasons you
because God's creation is getting [ __ ]
with
so let's both work together to stop this
look let's look at the Noah's story that
I mean you dissected it beautifully but
it's also really one of the most
important uh it's one of the most
important scientific stories in the
Bible it's basically God telling humans
all right I'm going to give you another
chance but to save yourselves you also
have to save all the animals because we
can't have a world without them this is
an argument for biodiversity Diane
that's a language that some people get
what what you've been doing is having
bills animals except oh oh come on it'll
like to let wait we're wasting what's
going on in the boat where he saved the
two cute kitty cats let's pan over
outside the boat where they're all
drowning it's the story was originally a
metaphor God kills baby you just bill
it's it's like watching Tom and Jerry
and saying how could that happen
look it's a story it's an allegory it's
a metaphor that it's a repository that
was the eating cure Sam if Americans
believe is true just because some people
are stupid enough to mistake to take a
take a take an empirical attitude to
your allegorical you're a fellow
traveler went you can't can't you see is
it I don't defend taking the Bible
literally as I can't get large part of
my life book painting any of it can you
see religion as a bookmark that that we
there's there's no there's nothing right
now that can satisfy some of these
larger Corrections we're a lot closer
than we were it's three years ago but we
it can be viewed as a bookmark until we
figure out what the act I don't think
that Jesus is a bookmark I think of it
as the beginning of a whole new era of
human consciousness yeah but but but but
but morality did not morality did not
start with Jesus morality did not begin
open and radically transformed by Jesus
if it was it was always canonized or
even if JJ spoke by social one hundred
and fifty years later
yeah well so more or less fictional yeah
no or or less fiction more or less
fictional people at both lies told by
people who didn't know
about him right well Paul wrote Paul
wrote close to Jesus Jesus died in 33
Paul wrote in the 50s the Gospels were
written between 70 and but they were
oral histories they were oral histories
passed along by st. Paul Chinese
whispers I know same but when you really
think about Jesus how come the papal
than the guy who lived closest to Jesus
knew nothing about him and the guy who's
lived 40 years later knew more about him
st. Paul didn't even know that he lived
on earth he's what he only lived in the
help heavenly realm because that's
that's completely not true that's
absolute lies it's Oh temple diseases
existed as a human being correct why is
it so taboo to say I don't look it up
man use the Google we gotta go thank you
Real Time with Bill Maher ask Bill and
his guests your questions right after
the show
at hbo.com or on Twitter